hallo
herzlich willkommen zur lief welt heute
gibt's kleine käsekuchen törtchen mit
orangen und feigen und ich finde das
super kompliziert aus ist also nach wie
vor so richtig an biberist
ich hab' ich habe es richtig rauch und
genau genau aber das ist super einfach
also muss bekommt sogar du hin was hatte
jeder bekommt das hinten habe ich
nämlich einen notweg boden als ist zwar
trotzdem und baic rezept einfach aus dem
ofen gebacken wird aber der boden
besteht trotzdem aus keksen und butter
super einfach das kommt dann in die
backform rein und dann wird eine kiss
kuchen masse gemacht mit orangenschale
und vanille natürlich und die kommt dann
eben drauf das wird gebacken und ich
habe so eine backform benutzt mit hebe
boden das heißt hier kann man den boden
ganz einfach heraus heben und die
törtchen sozusagen schwupps mit einem
finger herausheben und wir uns nicht
wenn man nicht genau dann nimmt man eine
ganz normale muffin vormund muss es halt
raus stürzen
das geht natürlich auch so sieht halt
ist eleganter aus und geht natürlich
auch viel einfacher und ja und dann habe
ich einfach noch so ein sirup gemacht
aus orange und honig und das ganze noch
mit feigen dekoriert super lecker und
ich würde sagen wir starten auch direkt
hier die fliege die umkreis nicht die
ganze zeit und ich zeige euch hier vorne
mal die zutaten
da das rote pferd sich die pflege
abgemacht
für den teig brauche ich 120 gramm
butter 150 gramm kekse da habe ich jetzt
butterkekse und auch ein paar
spekulation eine unbehandelte zitrone
und für die füllung 400 gramm frischkäse
im doppel ram stufe 400 gramm magerquark
80 gramm puderzucker 240 gramm stärke
und natürlich vanille extrakt und ihr
braucht auch noch eine unbehandelte
orange für die füllung die habe ich
jetzt leider nicht da weil der morath
die vergessen hat also die einkaufsliste
die hatte nur fünf zutaten und einen
davon hat er vergessen naja kann
passieren
es kamen noch unterwegs und holt wie
gesagt die orange die butter kann ich
jetzt schon mal hier in den topf
eingeben und bei geringer hitze
schmelzen
und in der zwischenzeit kann ich schon
mal die kekse zerkleinern
das mache ich jetzt hinten in dem mixa
ihr könnt aber auch zb die kekse in
einen gefrierbeutel film und dann mit
einem austausch darüber rollen
jetzt kann ich die textgröße mit sorge
schmerzen butter geben den herd habe ich
jetzt bereits ausgemacht
da kommt jetzt noch ein bisschen abrieb
von der zitrone dazu und daher ist es
auch wichtig dass der zitrone
unbehandelt ist genauso wie die orange
der moritz gerade noch holt
und jetzt können die zutaten einfach
verrührt werden
das habe ich die masse gut durchgemischt
und jetzt könnt ihr sie entweder in
einem wackligen reingeben mit 22
zentimetern durchmesser oder ihr macht
so wie ich mache nämlich mini törtchen
und nehmen stattdessen eine muffin form
und habe ich jetzt ne muffin frau mit
hebe boten dh diese blöden die sind hier
ganz locker drin und so kriegt man die
muffins später einfach ganz einfach
wieder raus
ihr könnt aber auch ganz normale muffin
förmchen nehmen müssten später raus
stürzen und damit es später nicht
anklebt wenn ich jetzt einfach mit back
grands prix besprühen und mit etwas
chris ausstreuen
wird es nämlich die brösel butter masse
und kann sie hier in die förmchen schön
glatt reindrücken
die vom ständig jetzt kurze den
kühlschrank damit der brösel wurden
schön fest werden kann
und in der zwischenzeit kann ich schon
mal die füllung zusammen würden und für
die füllung kann ich jetzt einfach alle
zutaten in eine rührschüssel geben das
heißt fisch käse magerquark puderzucker
die eier die stärke vanille extrakt und
gleich so bajorath es gebe ich noch den
abrieb der orange und auch den
orangensaft mit dazu
jetzt kann ich dir muffin förmchen
befüllen
das könnt ihr entweder mit einer
schöpfkelle oder einem löffel machen
oder mit einem spritzbeutel so kann ich
einfach ein bisschen sauberer arbeiten
und wenn ihr den spritzguss so vollmacht
ist es am besten wenn ihnen oben
verschließt entweder mit einem comet
könnt ihr mehrfach verwenden oder wenig
ein star hat neben dir ein bisschen
frischhaltefolie oder zum beispiel auch
ein klebeband
man kann oben nämlich nichts mehr raus
kommen jetzt unten eine spitze
wegschneiden und die machen firmen
befüllen
und jetzt noch zweimal klopfen und damit
die luft entweichen
und so kommen die törtchen jetzt in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei 190 grad ober
unterhitze für etwa 20 bis 25 minuten
die käse kuchen muffins sind jetzt
gebacken und ich habe sie auch ein
bisschen abkühlen lassen
jetzt wird es zeit für die dekoration da
habe ich jetzt hier ein bisschen honig
das sind jetzt etwa 60 gramm und den
honig gebe ich jetzt in einem topf okay
der löffel war nur für die deko da mit
lehm ständig ich nehme auch mein tag
schaut aber physisch ist dann später
echt cool oder fürs butterbrot morgens
ist ja auch cool
da gibt es noch die schale von einer
unbehandelten orange mit rein einfach
nur so ein bisschen zu viel muss es auch
nicht sein und dann gleich noch den
kompletten orangen sagt jetzt habe ich
den herd angemacht und lasse jetzt
einfach diese masse so sie ruckartig
einkochen
das heißt einmal kurz aufkochen lassen
und dann schaue ich einfach wie die
konsistenz wird und lass es ganz kurz
ein kochen und den derzeit kann ich hier
schon mal die deko weiter vorbereiten
und zwar habe ich jetzt hier ein paar
frische feigen die passen super dazu und
noch mal eine orange
die werde ich jetzt einfach in scheiben
und dann in kleine spalten schneiden
den sirup hab ich heruntergezogen und
zwar in dem moment wenn ganz viele
blogger bläschen aufsteigen
jetzt ist perfekt jetzt kann ich hier
den muffins ganz einfach heraus lösen
durch den hefe boden und jetzt hier
anrichten und die sind jetzt noch leicht
lauwarm ihr könnt sie gern lauwarm oder
auch schon abgekühlt werden
da kommt jetzt ein bisschen von dem guss
trüber nicht so viele das sind
dekorieren und wer will noch im grünen
klecks drauf mit minze und so es ist
eigentlich schon fertig und wir können
uns gleich probieren lieber morax
möchtest du probleme
natürlich ist es immer so spektakulär
demokratisch immer da wenn es dann essen
gibt und hat doch genug noch zu arbeit
für ihn mir hat noch genug
die freuen sich die jungen probleme man
muss ehrlich sagen das ist so richtig
sonst rezept wo man wenn man das mal
will ich am wochenende sei ja zuschauer
nicht zuschauern seinen gästen auch
tisch das sagen so krass wollte das
genau und wenn man jetzt keine zeigen
mag oder keiner da hat kann man
natürlich auch was ganz anderes
genau dann kann man ja auch keine ahnung
was hat gerade saison hat ok also
steigen wenn die re importiert ist
manche haben zwar ein feigenbaum aber
diese noch nicht so schön wird die aus
der türkei mit mehr sonne meer und sonne
& partners von käse co es ist käsekuchen
also cool aber echt coole auch der boden
richtig cool
lecker mit spekulatius so ein bisschen
die schon mal cool ist geht dann schon
in die weiterflüge richtung ja halt so
winterlich so eine winterliche richtung
cool winter nicht man kann es wirklich
komplett auch abwandeln man kann auch
unternehmen oder zitrone
man kann himbeeren drauf geben
und keine ahnung also alles was so recht
wie orange unbehandelter orangen und die
du gekauft hast ja ich habe patrick von
mir zeigt mal
und 2 die orangen runtergefallen beim
foto- und dann habe ich noch festgelegt
müsste natürlich den leuten sagen über
den anschlag als anschlag auf mich war
nicht so ganz also der schmeckt gut
sehr gut wird auch nach machen oder
super wenn ihr das auch gerne nachmachen
möchte dann können wir das genaue rezept
nochmal nachlesen auf sally blog.de und
ich wünsche euch ganz viel spaß dabei im
guten appetit und wir sehen uns beim
nächsten mal wieder biss dann wenn man
ganz berlin ist so groß da habe ich auch
so also man kann auch im 22 zentimeter
ring nehmen und das ganze auch als ein
töpfchen machen ich sitzen sonntags
video jetzt lieber erwarten wir warten
ein bisschen angespannt er und wir
warten auf den cds gruppe also ist bis
1500 zurzeit schaffst du es geschafft
hast du willst du schaffst es schon
vorher ich sagte schon 13 auch schon
fertig und hat es gekostet also 13
außerdem könnte hier machen oder auch
ein kombi natürlich er die backen ist
immer gleich im glauben ist das ist ein
einfaches rezept und ich denke quark und
so weiter hat sie sowieso immer da sie
hat eben den ähnlichen vorratsschrank
weg weil sie meine rezepte bisserl
analysiert hat und ich denke das problem
ist nur die feigen aber vielleicht hast
du dir auch noch überstehen wenn ich das
neue hobby
er stimmt wenn ich dann waren das ist es
auch also ich bin gespannt darauf wer
zuerst das rezeptors tipps das fertigen
und genau aussah und gruppe bis 13 uhr
im deutschen handball
sagt
so ich wollte gerade sagen und damit
keine sauerei entsteht nicht ans
waschbecken